[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halweg guten Abend schön dass Sie dabei
sind wie auch Norbert König für den
Sport guten Abend mehr als 100.000
Bürgerinnen und Bürger nutzten ihren
Samstag heute zum
Demonstrieren Massenproteste in
Deutschland immer mehr Menschen zeigen
in vielen Städten Flagge gegen
Rechtsextremismus
zwischen Union und AFD die
rechtskonservative werteunion um
exverfassungsschutzpräsident Maßen will
zur Partei werden und weltcupseg in
Antholz ein deutsches biathlonteam
Vanessa Fogt und Justus strelo gewinnt
erstmals die Single mixed
Staffel ein Demo Wochenende gegen
Rechtsextremismus 16 000 z.B in Halle
20.000 in Karlsruhe 35.000 in Frankfurt
am Main
Verfassungsschutzpräsident Haldenwang
begrüßte die Aktionen es sei
wünschenswert wenn die schweigende
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung klar gegen
Extremismus und Antisemitismus Position
beziehen würde sagte er der
Westdeutschen Zeitung im ganzen Land
gingen Menschen zusammen auf die Straße
bei rund 60 angemeldeten Aktionen ob
Kundgebung Mahnwache Menschenkette
Spaziergang oder Plakataktion der
Protest war vielfältig die Botschaft
klar gemeinsam für die dem
Marin ob in Karlsruhe Hannover Frankfurt
am Main oder Erfurt sie wollen ein
Zeichen setzen nach Bekanntwerden eines
Treffens rechtsradikaler in Potzdam
gehen mehr als 100.000 Menschen
bundesweit auf die Straßen bin gegen den
Faschismus praktisch hier also die AFD
hat ihre böse Fratze gezeigt ich sorge
mich um die Bürger die glauben dass es
dass die AFD eine tatsächliche
Alternative für den Rechtsstaat sei ich
hoffe dass mehr Leute mobilisiert werden
aktuell das ist jetzt auch die auf
aufrüttelt was zu tun die sonst nicht
unbedingt bei der Demo in der ersten
Reihe stehen in Hannover war eine der
größten Kundgebungen mehr als 35 000
teilnehmende Niedersachsens
Ministerpräsident Stefan weil rief dazu
auf klare Kante zu zeigen es gibt so
etwas wie eine ungeschriebene
Überschrift über unser
Grundgesetz nie wieder nie wieder
Nationalismus nie wieder Rassismus nie
wieder Hass nie wieder Unterdrückung nie
wieder ist es eine Momentaufnahme oder
ist es ein Protest der langfristig etwas
ändern wird konfliktforscher sehen
Potenzial für eine breite demokratische
Bewegung und sprechen von einem Ruck in
der Gesellschaft die Zivilgesellschaft
die notwendig ist für die Demokratie hat
einen Anlass eine Motivation gefunden
auf die Straße zu gehen und sie findet
gerade auch so etwas wie eine neue ident
die bundesweiten Proteste für die
Demokratie weiten sich aus und sie gehen
weiter im September sind in Thüringen
Sachsen und Brandenburg Landtagswahlen
in allen drei Bundesländern könnte die
AFD nach Umfragen stärkste Kraft werden
auch in Sachsen liegt sie im Moment vor
der CDU von Ministerpräsident kretschm
und ganz weit vor den mitregierenden
Grünen und SPD was tun gegen den Unmut
in der Bevölkerung das war den auch
zentrales Thema auf den Parteitagen von
CDU und SPD heute Thomas Bersch
berichtet mit 96% der Delegierten
Stimmen setzt die SPD Sachsen ihre ganze
wahlkampfhoffnung in die
Sozialministerin Petra Köpping lasst uns
während diesem Wahlkampf der
unheimlich krass sein wird das wird ein
schwerer Wahlkampf es wird ein
schicksalswahlkampf Umfragen sehen die
Partei in Sachsen gefährlich nahe an der
5% Hürde es ist die Stimmung im Land die
die SPD Werte drückt was mir oft
begegnet und ich bin viel unter im Land
unterwegs dass die Menschen diese
Polarisierung dies im Land gibt wirklich
leid sind dass sie sich deswegen
zurückziehen und dass sie deswegen sagen
ich ma da nicht mehr mit und die möchte
ich wieder motivieren heute setzte auch
ihn seine Partei auf Listen Platz 1
michael kritschm hatte die CDU auf einen
sachsenwahlkampf eingeschworen Schuld am
Unmut im Volk sei die Ampel in Berlin
diese Wahl wird eine
Richtungsentscheidung sein und wenn Sie
sich anschauen mit welcher eratischen
Politik derzeit in Berlin gearbeitet
wird dann ist uns glaube ich allen klar
die werden sich auch nicht daavon
beeinflussen lassen ob hier ein
Wahlergebnis schlecht ist für die
demokratische Mitte ob es hier eine
vernünftige Regierung gibt oder ob es
hier chaotische Verhältnisse gibt
schwierige Verhältnisse drohen durch
viele offene Fragen wie stark die AFD
wird oder wer es überhaupt in den
landtagschafft in Sachsen tun sich
unübersichtlich viele Varianten auf und
dann gibt es natürlich auch eine
Möglichkeit dass SPD und Linke nicht
mehr im Landtag sind aber die
wagenknechtpartei im Landtag ist die
dann zünglern an der Waage sein wird
entweder mit der AFD eine Regierung
bildet oder mit der CDU morgen laufen
die beiden Kandidaten bei Protesten
gegen Rechtsextremismus mit auch die
werden womöglich im Land noch einiges in
Bewegung
bringen noch vor den Landtagswahlen im
Osten bekommt deutsch eine weitere neue
Partei nach dem Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht
will nun auch die werteunion eine Partei
gründen und zwar zeitnah der bislang CDU
nahe Verein will nach eigenen Aussagen
konservativ liberal sein Chef ist der
ehemalige Verfassungsschutzpräsident
Hans-Georg mßen mehr von Melanie
Hag heute morgen in Erfurt kamen sie
noch als Verein zusammen doch bald
wollen sie eine Partei sein die
werteunion gibt es seit 2007
ein Sammelbecken für diejenigen denen
die Politik von Angela Merkel gerade bei
Klima und Migration nicht konservativ
genug war viele Mitglieder sind auch in
CDU und CSU offiziell aber war die
werteunion nie ein Teil der
Unionsparteien vorsitzender ist seit
einem Jahr hans- Georg Maßen ehemaliger
Chef des
bundesverfassungsschutzes sein Kurs
Zusammenarbeit auch mit der AFD laut
Pressemitteilung heute heißt es Zitat
die Partei wird in Zukunft
eigenständiger parteipolitischer Akteur
der keine Brandmauern pflegt und damit
gesprächsbereit in alle politischen
Richtungen ist noch ist men Mitglied der
CDU derzeit läuft ein
Parteiausschlussverfahren gegen ihn
Begründung unter anderem er benutze die
Sprache aus dem Milieu der Antisemiten
und
verschwörungsideologen bisin zu
völkischen
Ausdrucksweisen holen wir unsere
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Diana
Zimmermann dazu was bedeutet diese
Parteigründung für die Union ja so
kurzfristig löst sie ein Problem für die
Union wie ein Sprecher der CDU heute
sagte ist es nämlich so dass wer
Mitglied in dieser neuen werteunion wird
in dieser Partei der Zitat
der sogenannten werteunion darauf legte
die CDU heute wert dass es so genannt
ist der könnte nicht länger Mitglied in
der CDU sein das gilt dann natürlich
auch für Hans-Georg Maßen das
Parteiausschlussverfahren gegen ihn wäre
dann wohl nur noch eine Formalie
mittelfristig ist es aber natürlich so
dass die neue werteunion der alten Union
Verluste zufügen kann sie zielt ganz
klar auf den rechten Rand der CDU-Wähler
indem sie heute z.B sagte diese
Neugründung diese Abspaltung von der
Union wie sie sagt sei nötig denn die
CDU Rutsche immer weiter ins linksgrüne
Lager mm wenn die werteunion als Partei
antritt was heißt das für die
Parteienlandschaft ja wir hatten ja
gerade eine neue parteiengründung mit
dem Bündnis Sara wagenkrecht jetzt also
Wagenknecht nun also eine neue
Protestpartei die sie siedelt sich klar
zwischen AFD und CDU an und zielt eben
auf diese CDU-Wähler denen die AFD
womöglich zu Russland und China
freundlich ist tatsächlich ist es
natürlich so dass ich jetzt einerseits
dieses Spektrum rechts von der Union
vergrößern könnte mehr Wähler anziehen
könnte allerdings kann es auch dazu
führen dass sich die rechten Parteien
rechts von der Union gegenseitig
kannibalisieren vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzung Diana Zimmermann war das
aus
Berlin zu Beginn der Grünen Woche hat
das Bündnis wir haben es satt in Berlin
zu Protesten aufgerufen dazu gehören
rund 60 Organisationen die für eine
umweltgerechte Landwirtschaft ohne
Gentechnik eintreten am Rande der Demo
übergaben Teilnehmer ihre Forderungen an
Landwirtschaftsminister östemir
insgesamt kamen laut Veranstalter etwa
8000 Menschen in das Regierungsviertel
Motto gutes Essen braucht
Zukunft der ukrainische Präsident
selenski war war vor möglichen neuen
Kriegen wegen des so wörtlich Wahnsinns
der russischen Führung seinen alle
Nationen der Welt mit Unsicherheit
konfrontiert seit fast zwei Jahren wird
die Ukraine von Russland bombardiert
unsere reporterin Anne Brühl war
westlich von Kiev in schüomür in einem
Kinderheim auch dort zeigt sich was
dieser Krieg für die Menschen bedeutet
mitten im Wald liegt das Kinderheim von
schitomia 53 Kinder aus schwierigen
Familienverhältnissen leben keines älter
als se viele mit Beeinträchtigungen zu
Beginn des Kriegs waren sie evakuiert
jetzt sind sie zurück in der vertrauten
Umgebung dabei ist nichts wie
früher leider wissen die Kinder dass
jetzt nicht alles in Ordnung ist dass es
Krieg gibt in der
Ukraine Rollenspiele gegen die Angst
dabei soll es eigentlich um
Sprachentwicklung
gehen die Direktorin nimmt uns mit in
den Keller der jetzt ein Bunker ist
jedes Mal wenn es Luftalarm gibt müssen
die Kinder hier
runter klar haben die Kinder Ängste das
sind keine ruhigen Kinder für sie ist es
sehr schwer zu verstehen warum sie
nachts aus ihren warmen Betten geholt
und hierher gebracht werden das hier
sagt sie ist der einzige Ort wo die
Kinder fernsehen schauen dürfen tagsüber
kommen Sie gerne Toiletten eine Küche
alles ist da aber das Leben unter
ständiger Anspannung ist auch für die
nicht
einfach das ist eine große Qual für die
Seele das ist Schmerz großer Schmerz so
sollte es nicht sein aber jetzt ist es
so und auf der Welt sollten sich die
Leute nicht daran gewöhnen dass es in
der Ukraine Krieg gibt das ist nicht nur
unser Krieg das ist der Krieg der ganzen
[Musik]
Welten sing sie das Lied V Frost und
scheman der den
hozen für ein paar Augenblicke sollen
die Kinder den Krieg
vergessen in den Nahen Osten dort droht
ein Luftangriff in der syrischen
Hauptstadt Damaskus die Krise zu
verschärfen bei der Attacke auf ein
Wohnhaus wurden mindestens fünf
Mitglieder der iranischen
Revolutionswächter getötet unter ihnen
laut Staatsmedien zwei hochrangige
Geheimdienstmitarbeiter Iran machte
Israel für den Angriff verantwortlich
und drohte mit Vergeltung das
israelische Militär erte sich nicht zu
dem
Vorfall komplett anderes Thema jetzt die
kohs haben hier regelmäßig Urlaub
gemacht Kaiser Franz und seine Sissis
sowieso im Salzkammergut in Österreich
vor betörendem alpenp Panorama die ganze
Region ist dieses Jahr europäische
Kulturhauptstadt Bad ischel läutet das
Kulturjahr heute mit einer
tausendstimmigen jodeleröffnung ein doch
auch Salz spiegelt sich in der der Kunst
wieder denn das machte die Region ein
Reich Christian von
Rechenberg ein Jodler aus tausend Kehlen
die Sprache der Berge Hubert von geusern
lässt sie erklingen die Kulturhauptstadt
2024 ist
eröffnet nächster Auftritt die
Künstlerin kchita Wurst als Kaiserin und
Botschafterin was ist meine Botschaft
also für die
Kulturhauptstadt in die Welt hinaus
schaut mal wie unfassbar schön dieses
Stückchen Erde ist B ischel steht für
die ganze Region 23 Gemeinden haben die
Jury überzeugt etwa durch hochrangige
Künstler digitale Angebote und dass
diese viele Menschen einbeziehen Salz
hat das Salzkammergut ein reich und
berühmt gemacht in dieser Ausstellung
setzt man sich mit dem Mineral
auseinander in allerlei Farben und
Formen meine Performance hält das Salz
in Bewegung es bilden sich andauernd ne
ne Schichten die wieder zerfließen und
sich mit dem Stein ganz langsam
Vereinen doch die Kulturhauptstadt will
mehr als nur strahlen sie will Idylle
und Tradition einem Stresstest
unterziehen Fragen stellen wie gehen wir
mit Ressourcen um wie soll sich das
Handwerk entwickeln wohin strebt der
urbane
Raum Künstlerinnen wie Katharina zibulka
legen den Finger in Wunden sie
thematisiert Feminismus mit einem Satz
im Stile
tickere wir machen das immer gleich es
wird immer gestickt sozusagen dieses
Spannungsfeld zwischen männlich
dominierter Baustelle und weiblich
konnotierten Handwerk ist sozusagen
unser unsere Technik ein Jahr zeigt sich
das Salzkammergut zugänglich
nachdenklich und von seiner schönsten
Seite und noch mehr Kunst seine
Landschaftsmalerei berührt Menschen auf
der ganzen Welt Kaspar David Friedrich
ist einer der berühmtesten Maler deutsch
geboren ist er vor genau 250 Jahren in
Greifswald das nimmt die
Universitätsstadt zum Anlass ihren
berühmten Sohn in diesem Jubiläumsjahr
kräftig zu feiern heute ging es los Bern
Mosebach war dabei ein Schatz der das
Licht scheut und den das Pommersche
Landesmuseum nur alle jubiljah aus
seinem Depot holt kasp David Friedrich
der Marktplatz von
Greifswald hier steht sein Geburtshaus
der Vater ist kerzengießer und Sieder
Taufe im Dom
1774 Kindheit und Jugend in der
Hansestadt prägen ihn für sein ganzes
Künstlerleben erste zeichnerische
Versuche mit 14 im Jubiläumsjahr wird
die umfangreiche grafische Sammlung
erstmals nahzu vollständig
präsentiert diese frühen Zeichnungen
auch die späteren Zeichnungen noch die
bleiben in ihrer Machart konventionell
die sind da ist er Detail versessen da
sammelt er da sammelt der Eindrücke aus
denen er nachher seine Gemälde
zusammengesetzt hat so taucht etwa die
Klosterruine von elden vor den Toren
seiner Heimatstadt später vor dem
Panorama des Riesengebirges wieder
auf Bilder wie die Kreidefelsen von
Rügen machen ihn zu einem der
bedeutendsten deutschen Maler er ist ein
weltsuperstar und er ist eigentlich
derjenige der Romantik ins Bild gebracht
hat aber nicht kitchik sondern Romantik
als
Sehnsuchtsort am Abend die feierliche
Eröffnung des Jubiläumsjahrs im
greifswöer DO drei große Ausstellungen
und 160 Veranstaltungen erwarten die
Besucher dazu die zahlreichen
Originalschauplätze von greifwald in die
Welt 250 Jahre Kasper David
Friedrich ja toll für ein auch toll für
ein deutsches Biathlon du gab's heute
eine Premiere mm nie zuvor hat es einen
deutschen Sieg in einem Single mixed
Wettbewerb gegeben und das war für
Justus strelo und Vanessa Fogt beim
Weltcup in Antholz gleich im doppelten
Sinn ein besonderes Erlebnis in der
jüngsten Disziplin des
biatlandports Justus strelo und Vanessa
VOG 2 die in anholz gemeinsam ihren
ersten Weltcupsieg bejubeln können der
26-Jährigen Thüringerin gelingt ein
makelloser Auftritt am Schießstand 20
Treffer beim letzten Wechsel übergibt
Vanessa Vogt als führend an Justus
strelo die beiden deutschen zeigen eine
starke Laufleistung in der italienischen
leupe so fällt ein Nachlader beim
letzten Schießen des 27-Jährigen
Biathleten nicht mehr ins Gewicht es ist
der erste deutsche Sieg in einem Single
Mix Rennen auf Platz 2 landet das Duo
aus Norwegen vorteam
Österreich das deutsche
skispringerquartett hat dank starker
Flüge von Andreas Wellinger beim
teamweltcup in sakopane den dritten
Platz erreicht Wellinger Zweiter im
Gesamtweltcup sichert mit einem Sprung
auf
137inhalb m den Platz auf dem Podest ab
den Sieg holen sich ganz überlegen die
Österreicher vor
Slowenien im Handball wollen die
deutschen Nationalspieler nach dem Sieg
gegen Island am Abend in Köln Österreich
auf Distanz halten im zweiten
Hauptrundenspiel der
Europameisterschaft auf ihn wird es
wieder besonders ankommen Andreas Wolf
das Spiel gegen Österreich wird sein 150
Länderspieleinsatz und ein besonders
herausfordernder dazu denn die
Österreicher sind bei dieser EM noch
ungeschlagt ja österreich hat ist ist
schon die Überraschung Mannschaft dieser
dieser EM dies sind momentan Flow die
sind on fire die haben sehr sehr guten
Torhüter zwei Schlüsselspieler mit Bilik
und Lukas hutiik das Alpenland besiegt
Ungarn im ersten Hauptrundenspiel mit 30
Z 29 wenn die deutsche Mannschaft auf
Kurs Halbfinale bleiben will müssen sie
heute Abend die Nachbarn
bezwingen Borussia Dortmund bleibt 2024
ohne Gegentor nach dem 3:0 in Darmstadt
vor einer Woche heute noch ein klarer
Auswärtssieg 4:0 in Köln der erste FCK
Köln nach der fünften Heimniederlage
weiter in Not nach einer 40minütigen
Halbzeitpause wegen blockierter
Rettungswege erzielt matusch Bero
Bochums Siegtor gegen Stuttgart Freiburg
zu ze noch 3:2 gegen Hoffenheim
Heidenheims Jan NAS Niklas Beste kommt
nach dem 1:1 gegen Wolfsburg um 11 Uhr
ins aktuelle Sportstudio darin
ausführlich das abendliche Topspiel
Leipzig gegen Leverkusen und da haben
wir noch Darmstadt gegen Frankfurt
2:2 das Freitagsspiel Mainz Union wurde
dagegen abgesetzt morgen noch zwei
Partien und in der Tabelle bleibt
Leverkusen nach dem 18 Spieltag vorn
Dortmund jetzt fünf Punkte oder mehr vor
der Konkurrenz für die Europapokalplätze
in der unteren Hälfte ist Union Berlin
jetzt schon mit zwei Spielen im
Rückstand dahinter das elf Punkte Trio
Mainz Köln stad und schließlich noch
erfreuliches von Alexander Z der 26
Jahre alte Tennisprofi bleibt im Rennen
um den Grand Slam Tiel in Melbourne er
gewinnt souverän in der dritten Runde
gegen den US Teenager Alex
mckelsen Finale wartet der Brite Cameron
nor wie alt ist Alex melson 19 okay
gerade noch Teenager sein Ken der
dauerfost morgen
vorbeiur
über Null ein bisschen Sonne gibt's auch
die Details hat gleich chr das heute
journal mit Marietta slomker um vi uh
und wir sind morgen wieder da danke für
Ihr Interesse einen schönen Abend noch
und auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend für viele ist
traumhaftes kaltes Winterwochenende -19°
gab es heute morgen im Oberstdorf im
Allgäu aber am Montag stellt sich das
Wetter komplett um es wird deutlich
wärmer in Köln z.B gibt es am Montag
Andi am Mittwoch schon über 10° und
nachts keinen Frost mehr das liegt an
diesem Tief dass da jetzt über den
Atlantik auf uns zugerauscht kommt mit
milderer Luft allerdings auch mit Regen
und Sturm heute Nacht wird es aber noch
mal knackig kalt im Norden 0 bis -5°
sonst -7 bis -15 Grad kalt vor allem
überschnee und bei Aufklaren und das ist
vor allem in der Mitte und im Süden der
Fall im Norden ziehen etwas mehr Wolken
durch da treht der Wind auch schon auf
Süd und frischt auf so ist es morgen im
Nordwesten dann starkböhig mit
sturmböhen an der Nordsee und auf den
Berggipfeln ganz im Norden zieht auch
immer mal wieder ein paar Regentropfen
ein paar Schneeflocken von West nach Ost
durch Richtung Südosten sieht man aber
häufig die Sonne außerdem kommen die
Temperaturen aus dem dauerfrostbereich
hinaus die liegen dann zwischen 2 und
9°. am Montag gibt es dann schon
Temperaturen bis 11° mit Sturm und Regen
der in Bayern auch mal gefrieren kann
und mit viel Wind Regen und Temperaturen
bis 13° geht es in der Woche dann weiter
und damit tschüss